true greatness is often fleeting zio was
exposed prey actually dies with his
ultimate up the featherstone wasn't even
used in the fight there's no appeal for
him as khan wants to turn around to kill
yeah looks for it actually does a decent
job there on the fake of the flash oh my
god finds the weak point now wolf he's
in trouble the double kill for khan khan
is one of the best top laners of all
time for years he's been considered a
god of the game
oh my god the triple stone massive
keyboard triple kill quadrangle is this
gonna be the bento he's gonna be
delivered at this time
first ribbon in three years pentakill
for khan and the 2-0 the king's own
dragon x you make it away but here comes
pawn they're looking for the dive three
members trying to go under this turret
there's the flash stun there's the burst
damage but whoa he gets killed at the
turret there's no way to flash away a
car gets away because barrel goes for
the engage but he gets completely
interrupted life now trying to run out
of this one oh man
and yet
victory escaped him time and time again
and there is nothing left to stop
samsung galaxy as they take down their
first opponent they are the first in the
semi-finals and who can really stop this
team
god can he get it done he can't the
vladimir they can't do it this is it the
greatest team in the history of league
of legends taken down by the greatest
team europe has ever produced worlds
2021 was khan's last chance to find
glory before retirement his story would
either end in triumph or tragedy
but no matter how it ended khan became a
legend card hungrily greedily looking
for it inspired is not sticking into him
he tp's canyon goes in for the damage
khan comes in couple more shots
for khan
[Music]
khan has pretty much always been one of
league's hottest talents he was scouted
out of solo queue as a kit then played
for minor korean and chinese teams
before getting signed to xiaogu as a sub
in the lpl but his big break came as the
starting top laner for wongju gaming in
the 2017 summer split isaiah was exposed
prey actually dies with his ultimate up
the featherstone wasn't even used in the
fight there's no appeal for him as khan
wants to turn around to kill yeah looks
for it actually does a decent job there
on the fake of the flash oh my god finds
the weak point now wolf he's in trouble
the double kill for khan longzhu were
struggling and khan burst onto the scene
by immediately turning their fortunes
around they beat sk telecom t1 in the
summer finals and went to worlds as the
number one seed from korea yeah we was
always going to split up else
skt is rooney just on the wrong side of
this battle they can just focus down
this nexus and that's what prey is
starting to do wolf jumps his way
through the quickness it's just going to
spell his death if blank is not tanky
right now the beast doesn't do anything
fake is going to explode as the massive
damage from frey is going to say good
night to the king of the mid lane the
nexus falls and your new champions of
the lck it's long 2 gaming
if you predicted
to finish top five you would have been
laughed out of the room by everyone if
you predicted longzhu to win the grand
final they still would have been
laughing atlas but no one is laughing
today there are tears in the eyes of
longzhu's faces because they have beaten
the champions they have beaten the gods
and long shoe gaming are going to worlds
at worlds khan was hailed as the best
top laner in the game and was considered
one of the best players at the
tournament
but unfortunately khan's first ever run
at worlds ended in disaster when samsung
galaxy knocked out longzhu with a 3-0 in
the quarter-finals the rest of the team
ready to push through the bot lane the
wave already pushed the inhibitor easy
to drop samsung galaxy defying
expectations 3yo was a likely result but
not in the way you expect here as they
look to knock down bdd he can barely
wave through the protocol to land the
stun the route the ace and there is
nothing left to stop samsung galaxy as
they take down their first opponent they
are the first in the semi finals and who
can really stop this team
[Applause]
and yet despite the devastating loss the
narrative around khan didn't really
change
he was still one of league's most
exciting top laners and more importantly
he was a fan favorite the crowd loved
the fact that he was a solo queue
superstar living the dream and that he
had the attitude to match
[Music]
[Applause]
so i just want to say one last thing to
all the top laners in the world
uh keep this in mind if you lose it's
not your fault but the jungler's spot
okay well
not everyone loved khan's goofy attitude
though and some thought it was even
impacting his performance
this is a guy that throughout his career
he had ups and downs people were saying
khan is a choker khan can't do this he's
not serious enough blah blah blah but
khan brushed off the doubters he knew he
was one of the best in the world he just
needed to grind out a little longer for
that big international win and yet at
tournament after tournament
khan fell short there goes levy's soul
it's caught up by cards
he's got the ultimate available gorilla
is not gonna be able to save
[Applause]
[Applause]
champions can fall
gods can bleed where were you when the
west rose up to conquer champions g2
esports eliminates sk telecom
north america face europe at the msi
finals
the ulti comes out at such a close
exchange for now they're winning but
perks is coming in this is his hero
moment if he wants to turn this fight in
favor of team this could be the game
against the final moment
he's next on the list there's no way he
could duly yeah it's coming
vladimir they can't do it this is it the
greatest team in the history of league
of legends taken down by the greatest
team europe has ever produced han was
still being hailed as one of the best in
the world but he always fell inches
short of glory after three years of
being considered one of the best top
laners in the game
khan still didn't have his victory
something had to change
[Music]
khan returned to china and jumped to fpx
for the 2020 season hoping to find
victory on the defending world champions
roster everybody thought that khan was a
massive upgrade for fpx and that the
2019 champions might be able to run it
back
but khan ended up splitting a lot of
time with gimgoon and neither of them
ended up helping the team qualify for
worlds
one two minions with rookie tping in
with the baron buff and those death
timers you know where they're heading
yep they're going straight for the nexus
they're going straight to lgd tomorrow
to make that impossible run when
everyone counted invictus gaming out
they showed up in a game five lgd
are you watching the regional qualifiers
are invictus gaming's speciality goodbye
fbx the 2018 world champions are coming
next by the end of 2020 the narrative
around khan had shifted he was still an
amazing player sure but his middling
year on fpx marta's reputation after all
if he couldn't even qualify for worlds
with the defending world champions on
his side
what hope did he have of ever lifting
the summoner's cup and to make things
worse khan was running out of time
in korea mandatory conscription has
ended a lot of promising esports careers
sure there are some ways to delay
service but it looms over every great
korean startup
in july 2021 khan said that this was
going to be his last season he didn't
have any more ways to delay his military
service retirement was imminent
this meant that 2021 was going to be his
last chance to win worlds one last ride
to prove that he was once again the
greatest top laner in the world
and so once again khan teamed up with
the best he joined damn one the
defending world champions and dominated
korea because beryl goes for the engage
but he gets completely interrupted life
now
finds a four-man wallop afterwards gets
congratulated with that first blood and
genji limp away fly's gonna get burned
down by the death ray ruler in a bit of
trouble canyon is going to stun him up
and show maker takes the kill canyon was
down the lake what what else all right
well congratulations for your series mvp
canyon the nexus falls down and don juan
kia get the 3-0 over genji and we'll be
your spring lck champions you're on the
opposite side of this poke they're just
trying to get the smite down on time and
whitney coming in but showmaker has the
damage and he takes out two but the
infernal soul will go the way of t1
can owner and connor salvation know and
tom what kia will be your champions of
lck summer 2021 in a devastating three
to one victory khan replaced nuggery on
damn one who many considered to be the
new best top laner in the game so he had
some pretty big shoes to fill if he
wanted to live up to his old reputation
khan returned to korea humbled by his
experience on fpx he played a more
supportive background role on damon
instead of carrying like he used to many
people thought he was washed but his
playstyle evolved
damon won everything domestically
emerging as by far the strongest team
from one of the strongest regions in the
world
and yet at msi international victory
escaped khan once again last remaining
nexus turret is at one quarter hp the
minions are coming in and rng is going
forward kryon goes after the enemy 80
carry but he's not able to find him
canyon will die first rng they're on the
nexus don juan has no ability to stop
this it's game over to be the best you
gotta beat the best and rng take down
the world champs to become your msi
champions of 2021 the lpl are kings
again
still damon entered worlds as the clear
favorites this was khan's best chance to
win and he was going to make it count
now the hope is alive for rose stunned
into the hook last and almost down but
he popped the stopwatch just in time
supreme is saying talent will come out
it's a double for khan betty the hope
was there for rogue but immediately it's
slammed right back in their faces canyon
and khan can do no wrong and summer
tries to get away but khan gets the
quadra can he do it can he find the
penta here for don juan kia canyon's
gonna chase down inspired card hungrily
greedily looking for it inspired is not
giving it to him he's tp's canyon goes
in for the damage khan comes in couple
more shots
for khan game one kicked off worlds with
a perfect 6-0 group stage no other team
at the tournament looked that dominant
and that dominance continued as they
stomped madeline's with a 3-0 sweep and
madeline's may have found a car here but
khan is having none of it pops the
stopwatch slices through mad lions
khan in his last worlds doesn't even
want to lose a game
undefeated nine and oh dam one kia
in the pursuit of perfection they are
found worthy once again and they will
fight t1 in semis
but khan's real challenge began in the
semi-finals
because now he was facing the only
player with more lck titles than him the
man who won three world championships
while khan couldn't even win one
faker domestically khan has had faker's
number in the past khan has the second
most lck titles behind faker and also
handed the goat his only lck finals
losses this time he was backed up by
four young up-and-coming players ready
to follow his lead to victory this was
faker's chance for a return to his
former glory but khan still needed that
one win and he'd have to go through the
goat to get it
keep your eyes on khan body slam flash
is an option he's gonna move in faker
flashing over the wall just trying to
make it up safety but canyon on the
chase he's gonna find the root on the
faker the stun into the wall and there
is barrel the gold lead two big dom one
kia dominated the early game and they're
gonna remind t1
why they were the favorites coming into
this series as they run them down show
maker the low on mana leaping back
kubushi maybe you can get the shutdown
no holding on for now carry on goomby
usually want to get something done but
ghost will get a bit of revenge and now
carrie has to run for the hills the body
slam flash the ace coming in for don
juan kia everything being bet on this
smite okay we're going to sleep connor
now stepping forward 3k getting lower
you're trying to lock up who's going to
get it no in the end it is canyon when
it matters most you will find this fight
but you she's standing strong on the
back side it does not matter and the
face of the elder dow juan kia will wipe
t1 off the map they're gonna tp top as
well they have the elder dragon they
have a wave they have everything they
need to go to the world finals and damn
old legends and old legacies goodbye
faker goodbye t1 hello dom juan and show
maker they will defend their title in
the finals and look to go back to back
now there was only one team left
standing between khan and the trophy
he'd been seeking for four years
edward gaming and ruler sees his kingdom
fall to ashes he's got no turrets left
he's got no life left and he's got no
road left the world championship
pfeiffer puts in a couple of shots bdd
is going to die and die and the nexus
falls and edg the last of the lpl are
headed to their first world final
welcome to finals edg
what a performance here five games for
both of these semi-finals
and dom one the final boss will await
them there while damon were favorites
from day one of worlds edg's chances
were a little less clear
while they had a strong performance in
summer and they were china's number one
seed at the tournament their inability
to perform at worlds was legendary but
edg broke their curse and made it all
the way to the finals still the road
there wasn't exactly clean and pretty
much everyone expected damn one to win
it all
it was all up to khan now this was going
to be his last ever professional series
and if there was ever a time to go out
in a blaze of glory
this was it and for a series that so
many predicted was a 3-0 yes it might be
but it's not going to be for someone
gear edward gaming absolutely wiping the
floor with our former world champions
they make sure they finish the job
before they finish off the nexus the
drake also in the in goes jj but not
quite able to get the work done that he
wants it to there's the mimic distortion
but no damage pfeiffer still able to
take down canyon but is it actually
gonna work out jj flashing for his life
and viper high health bar but he doesn't
have any friends and it's a double kill
for khan who is getting his revenge
right now jj that was the wrong brush to
face checkers beryl could go down but no
it's a triple kill for the graves on the
top side the only one here that can try
to defend jj up relatively soon mako as
well viper also only five seconds but
the nexus is exposed and darwin kia will
move to match points in this series and
edg should be taking this game in fact
laundry he's taking inhibitors himself
rumors of the lpo's demise have been
greatly exaggerated
this year my friends edg will just put a
stomp down on game number four push us
to silver scrapes push us to that game
five alice now they both have a match
point we are going the whole distance
the series was literally back and forth
and it all came down to game five
khan's last professional game ever
could he finally win the trophy that had
eluded him for so long we don't know
where he is mako goes in pops
immediately like a volume canyon going
to follow soup laundry gets exhausted
and khan now trying to continue this
fight some low health bars as the flash
comes forward khan goes golden
viper is still alive though flashes in
showmaker down to 200 he's a sitting
duck and it's a double kill for scout
now he's flashing forward picking up all
of the summoner spells and it is good
night for ghost and an ace for edg in
order to close this one out right here
there is one turret between edg and
history right now is viper dashes
forward showmaker goes golden but it's
not going to keep him alive mako is
going to be the sacrificial left but
it's a double kill already but laundry
lightning rushing his way out of this
one and now the nexus is exposed oman
kia are limping and edg at the man
advantage the nexus will go down and
against all odds
edg will be your 2021 world champions
they've done it they've actually done it
the lpl is back on top bettia's
combo breaker on dom one's attempt for
the back-to-back titles
not every story has a scriptwriter and
not every career gets an ending that
lives up to its legacy but even though
he didn't win khan's legacy remains
intact
in the end the attitude that made him a
fan favorite all those years ago shone
through
instead of dejected stares and mumbled
apologies khan told his team to blame it
all on him to stay positive seeing how
jovial he was seeing how proud of his
team he was and the way that they
navigated that press conference with
like laughter and jokes and being able
to take the mickey out of himself uh as
it were with you know telling his
teammates just blame it on top gap you
know and
i think that that really
tells khan's story almost completely you
can argue that khan is one of the best
players to never win worlds but that
doesn't feel like an appropriate legacy
see khan wasn't just a great player he
tried to bring fun and personality to a
region that needed it
and even when he fell short of his
ultimate goal he faced his tragedy with
a smile he reminded us that true
greatness isn't measured in tournament
wins
it comes from being remembered as
someone truly special he's the joker
he's the guy that likes to goof around
and we had you know peanut be a little
bit of that and have a bit of that sort
of personality but
we've never had a player like khan and i
don't know when we will again
[Laughter]
what's up
this is